c'est un copain m'a singainy jour où
d'accord si on rigole on perd un point
c'est moi d'accord d'accord
attention attention 3 2 à 1
alors on est venus s'amuser
oui j'ai même pas parler mon copain est
alors assez partie attention ça s'est
fait assez fait attention
2 1
si j'ai regardé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette hausse de 0,6 il est sûr attention
attention à les attentions 3 3
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu vois mais qu'une bande à la règle et
la lumière
bon bah écoutes je sais quoi séduire
paix 52,3 eur store fait la nique
dernière attends attends attends je
charge et toi c'est tout les mêmes
mady adore cette fois c'est fait rien
qui règne à moi c'est faire lâcher plus
d'idées alors attends je m'en [ __ ] une
comme ça ou à ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est un copain martin gagné
[Applaudissements]
on connaît la veille de sa mort km et
j'aimerais lui dire si lui l'a réussi
comme je l'aï dit qu'il est
[Applaudissements]